moi la seule chose qui m'intéresse c'est
de bien vivre la minute qui m'est donnée
comme à présent de bien vivre celle
d'après de bien vivre de main et le
reste je m'en fous
quand on s'intéresse un peu à toi on
découvre que tu es un personnage
finalement beaucoup plus complexe que tu
en as l'air le dimanche après-midi à la
télévision un peu comme des poupées
russes qui qui s'emboîtent je valide les
poupées et soviétiques
et le premier personnage celui que tout
le monde connaît c'est le Jacques Martin
disons un peu comme ça un peu démago
faut bien le dire quoi un peu un peu
populaire non je sais pas je t'ai vu
dimanche dernier à la télévision alors
tu disais dans mon émission c'est le
monde est à vous il y a pas de gagnant
il y a pas de perdants c'est des gens
qui disent on a gagné parce que toute
façon on est tous dans le même bateau
depuis Vercingétorix
on est quand même pas tous dans le même
bateau il y a quand même des gens qui
sont dans des dans des bars et d'autres
qui sont dans des yacht non oui parce
que les
[Musique]
parce que la nature fait que les choses
sont inégales au départ mais je pense
que quand on a la chance d'avoir un gros
bateau il faut aider les petites
barcaques
je crois que s'il existe une chevalerie
de ce que j'appelle entre guillemets les
intellectuels mais genre de ça c'est de
mettre son point d'honneur à ne jamais
se servir de ce que l'on sait au dépend
de gens que savent pas alors
le dimanche je ne fais pas de démagogie
j'aime ces gens ces gens font partie
intégrante de ma vie et je faisais cette
réflexion faut pas la dégager ce grand
texte à propos de chansons de chant que
j'avais entendu qui m'inquiétait on a
gagné on a gagné ça veut dire qu'on a
perdu
[Musique]
alors quand tu vas à la Concorde et que
tu dis dans François que tu as pris le
risque de tes situations soient menacées
tu sais bien qu'avec l'Audi Matt que tu
fais sur la 2 le dimanche après-midi ta
situation n'est pas menacée
enfin je lui avais laissé cette émission
elle faisait 28 non que j'ai quand même
une certaine habitude de la télé ça fait
35 ans que j'en fais et c'est pas moi
qui suis inquiet parce que moi
personnellement ça ne m'inquiète pas
trop tu vois mais
ce sont mes camarades autour de moi qui
ont voté un risque en allant à la
Concorde oui à certains si on est
vraiment un professionnel en travaillant
sur une radio d'état les gens savent
bien qu'en prenant position quand on le
pouvoir
généralement ça se paye mais je dis pas
je te dis pas que le qu'on va me virer
non tu avais une candidate
de me faire chier tu avais une candidate
qui a fait zéro alors un candidat à café
0 alors tu dis on va toute façon moi
aussi quand je fais à l'école j'avais
toujours 0
et puis c'est pas grave d'avoir zéro
alors on sait jamais si tu as eu le
certificat d'étude seulement ou le
baccalauréat ça s'est arrêté où tes
études ça officiellement
ça c'est oui j'ai eu le certificat
d'études j'ai eu le brevet et puis c'est
bien bien bien bien bien plus tard j'ai
commencé mes études j'ai recommencé mes
études mais est-ce que ça c'est pas tout
ça de la provocation un peu contre les
intellos et la gauche caviar que tu
détestes en militaire
et si à l'occasion
d'un nouveau mai 68 il y avait quelque
chose j'irai placé quelques grenades à
l'observateur
oui ce sont mes ennemis de castes ça
fait 30 ans que ces gens là
sur ce que je fais sur mes livres sur
mes films
sur mes émissions de télé alors pendant
une vingtaine d'années j'en ai eu peur
voilà donc oui je vous remercie de
m'avoir dit dans le journal que j'étais
un enfant et voilà même je leur disais
bon je le soir quand j'ai rencontré chez
Castel parce que la gauche va chez
Castel
et puis un certain moment on évolue tu
vois j'ai attrapé mes 55 ans et pas mal
d'autres choses aussi et je me suis dit
que j'étais complètement con de baptiser
avec mes ennemis donc maintenant tu la
rendes clientèle il faut savoir que
maintenant je vais tirer leur tirer les
tirer eux parce que la gauche que je
déteste c'est pas bien entendu les
communistes ou les gens qui sont
vraiment du peuple c'est les fausses
sagouins
les petits [ __ ]
de commerce comme si dire de quelqu'un
que c'était un représentant de commerce
c'était une nageur c'est ça heinisme tu
étais représentant de commerce
mais ce que je veux dire c'est que
quelque part c'est fini je ne sais plus
de concession mais ennemis il faut qu'il
le sache tu dis pour quelqu'un qui est
pas franc-maçon et qui fait pas partie
du Racing je me suis pas mal démerdé ça
tu as non j'ai pas de revanche à prendre
de toute façon je vais
maquette n'est pas ici quand on a 55 ans
mathématiquement on a moins le temps
moins de temps à passer sur cette terre
qu'on en a déjà oui ça c'est sûr on a
fait le plus gros bon on a fait le plus
gros hein si on veut diminue 55 par 2 ça
ferait 110 on n'y arrive pas c'est sûr
donc il me reste moins de temps à passer
et comme je suis un si barrique que
j'aime le bonheur que j'aime vivre que
j'aime la vie passionnément je ne vais
plus m'emmerder et beaucoup plus jeune
que les autres je suis arrivé à un état
raisonnable je les histoires de la terre
ne me concernent pas tellement parce que
le même si je connais comme était un
meurtre aujourd'hui le minimum dont je
courais écopé serait inférieur autant
qu'il me reste donc j'en ai rien à
[ __ ] qui tu détestes plus dans la
gauche caviar mais personne personne je
trouve pénible certaines attitudes par
exemple je trouve très très pénible
l'attitude de Guy Bedos la semaine
dernière et si j'étais France comme
Mitterrand je convoquerai big en lui
disant arrêtez vous me faites du temps
une fois que perdre des voix oui parce
que tu vois dans l'émission de ce charme
en copain il a été faire comme notre
charme de Chavanne de Chavanne qui
démarre son émission qui est là tout
timide parce qu'on est timide les 15
premières années on fait de la
télévision si si il faut 15 ans pour
cesser d'une timide et voilà que Guy
fait du terrorisme et lui dit une chose
méchante qui m'a frappé si vous
continuez cette émission je verrai
faites-le en français c'est agréable
quand on sait le doute qui habite de
Chavannes ce garçon timide tellement
timide qui parlent vite par peur d'avoir
un trou et d'un charmant garçon il lui a
dit je fais la première et sans doute la
dernière tu vois est-ce que tu crois que
de la part d'un mec qui a bientôt 60 ans
de la bouteille il a 60 ans
plus ça vous coûte 70 alors est-ce que
tu crois que c'est bien qu'avec de 60
ans riche parce que c'est cher les
spectacles viennent faire du terrorisme
intellectuel auprès de Chavanne qui
commence alors que de Chavannes est un
charme en garçon est-ce que c'est bien
de la part de Guy Bedos doté le pain du
match torigore qui est un ami et qui
fait qui a inventer les parfums pour
attirer dans ce qu'on a le droit quand
on a une place de tirer sur le gagne pas
les autres non bah disons que je trouve
cette attitude
négative mais je le déteste pas ben non
c'est pas de sa faute c'est un enfant
malheureux prolongé alors il y a un
autre Martin c'est le Martin écorché
c'est le Martin qui a souffert quand il
était petit mais tout le monde a
souffert j'ai souffert jusqu'à
j'ai souffert j'ai souffert mais tout le
monde c'est vrai que ton père est revenu
de la guerre de 14 alcoolique à cause de
ce qu'il avait vu pendant la guerre oui
mon père a fait la guerre de 14-18
parfois parce que je suis curieux tout
ça c'est intéressant à raconter c'est ce
que je vais raconter enfin liste la
comédie musicale que je
qu'on va donner à au théâtre Marigny à
partir du 22 septembre ça s'appelle la
lune avec les dents et c'est l'histoire
d'un mec qui s'appelle Martin Dupont ou
durant qui est né en 1933 et
il monte il fait sa vie et c'est ce que
j'ai croisé le nom de ma route c'est ça
et c'est drôle mais est-ce que t'as pas
été embringué finalement dans la télé
comme ça parce que tu avais 6 enfants à
nourrir
dans la télé parce que j'avais eu un
chagrin d'amour avec le cinéma
quand mon film est sorti on avait tourné
à Nice et je crois qu'il y avait
beaucoup de choses dedans beaucoup de
choses formidables et bien avant la
lettre et puis
les intellectuels de gauche mon tiré
dedans le film par time on dirait dedans
et il a bien fallu payer le film alors
je suis en train à la télé mais quand tu
as quitté midi magazines la première
fois tu as dit par goût de la sécurité
ou par l'acheter je pourrais rester là
et puis finalement si je restais là j'y
serai encore dans 30 ans
est-ce que finalement c'est pas ce qui
était arrivé j'y suis pas là c'est 30
ans ça fait 10 ans que je suis rentré en
plus qu'est-ce que je me marre parce que
je suis très loin de la maison mère j'ai
un théâtre 41 avenue de Wagram j'ai la
même équipe petite équipe courte depuis
pas de pays donc je fais de la télé et
on est très très très très très très
très très très très loin des discussions
de Gaulois ou du côté et comme la maison
Antenne 2 a confiance en moi je suis un
petit peu gouverneur général
j'envoie de temps en temps quelqu'un
chercher des trombones ou des enveloppes
à la maison mère à la maison mère mais
en dehors de ça le théâtre de l'Empire
on fait tout nous-mêmes et les livres tu
regrettes pas de t'en avoir écrit parce
que tu en as fait un autre
extraordinaire je crois la résurrection
je crois fortement
on va pas faire de racisme justement
c'est ça mais je crois à la résurrection
tu vois il y a un écrivain américain qui
s'appelle Richard bac qui a écrit une
phrase définitive sur lequel tous les
êtres humains devraient méditer il faut
bien écouter ça
ce que la chenille appelle la fin du
monde le maître lui l'appelle le
papillon et je pense exactement ça nous
sommes des chenilles mais quelque part
si on se place sur un autre degré moi je
sais qu'on ressuscite en papillon et
j'en ai même la preuve mais pour être
sûr de ne rien rater de Inna larditude
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu